et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
come back cette semaine à commencer par
une polémique comme seul ce joli pays
sait en produire cahuzac à l'assemblée
nationale dsk au sénat bah je vois pas
ce qui est choquant ça fait un an qu'on
a hero à matignon
politique toujours la menace brune a été
écarté de villeneuve sur lot c'est vrai
que c'est une menace terrible c'est vrai
moi j'ai entendu parler le gars du fn la
bousquet-cassagne
mon épicier chinois a plus d'éloquence
alors qu'il parle pas français
en tout cas si durant les municipales
2014 il y aura ce fameux raz-de-marée du
fn qu'on annonce un ca risque de sentir
assez vite la mouler le bulot dans les
mairies
politique et morale bernard tapie qui
est fort c'est moi c'est mon héros quoi
ce mec c'est vraiment c'est le seul type
qui est capable d'arriver en garde à vue
et de se débrouiller pour qu'on accuse
aussi son avocat
[Applaudissements]
lui se balade toujours avec un avocat de
secours on sait jamais si on s'est
habitué à ce stade tapie doit avoir un
double des clés de sa cellule
cc c'est vraiment un gâchis a vu ses
affinités avec la justice au lieu de
perdre son temps à lancer des journaux
ferez mieux de racheter fresnes où les
baumettes et puis de
serre et quand on regarde sa carrière
d'entrepreneur la seule boîte qui fait
tourner c'est le parquet
politique toujours
montebourg déclare que barroso est le
carburant du fn et un port tard
montebourg ça fait longtemps que le fn
carbure à l'arabe et aux roms plutôt qu
aux portugais
je crois je crois mais
c'est quand même c'est étonnant cette
situation à portugais ultralibéral
patrons de l'europe à quand un taliban
membres des feymen
justice selon un ex détenu dans les
prisons chinoises les prisonniers font
des écouteurs pour des compagnies
aériennes
70 heures par semaine payées 1 euro j'ai
essayé de faire le calcul horaires mon
ordinateur a planté deux profs mois
alors évidemment on a forcément ça
donnait des idées on a essayé la même
chose dans les prisons françaises ça n'a
pas marché les matons n'était pas assez
travailleur
sport affaires jalabert c'est terrible
ce qui arrive est est ce vraiment
nécessaire d'accabler un type dont le
palmarès prouve que le dopage ne marche
pas
[Applaudissements]
non mais il a gagné quatre étapes du
tour dans sa vie quand on a dû lui
injecter un placebo c'est pas possible
alors moi j'ai vu son témoignage alors
c'est laisser les aveux à la jalabert
quoi en terme de défense virenque à côté
ce maître vergès c'est vraiment le type
web os j'arrivais dans leur roulotte on
me faisait des soins il souhaité et le
type iran dans la caravane ils montrent
un genou écorché on veut dire non on va
pas prendre de risque on va faire deux
piqûres une transfusion comme ça sera
bien désinfecter tue c'est dingue est
pas rien et jalabert ça doit être le
seul mec qui fait un séjour en thalasso
et qui s'étonne qu'ils aient pas de
machine à dia liste
alors cette année on nous promet repas
de dopage pas de dopage se sont il n'ya
pas il n'ya pas besoin qu est-ce que
qu'est-ce que le tour de france c'est
quoi 3400 km 21 étapes deux jours de
repos six étapes de montagne moyenne de
40 km heure en général tu prends deux
gouttes d'huile essentielle de ma tante
ses bons
[Applaudissements]
scores toujours laurent blanc nommé au
psg bah c'est normal c'est la période du
repêchage au bac
le choix de laurent blanc sait vraiment
comment dire tu sais quand tu es
dimanche ton frigo est vide pitt arrive
lundi matin au supermarché les rayons
sont pas encore remplies et a qu'une
boîte de cassoulet leader price qui est
encore là tu vas et tu dis ben ça m'a
fait penser à laurent blanc
fonction publique les navettes changer
le profil des élèves qu'elle recrute
alors maintenant l'école désir des
candidats avec de la personnalité et des
exemples de transparence la personnalité
et de la transparence enfin ça va donner
des mick jagger en plexiglas
n'essaie pas
taxi parisien samy naceri
a brisé une vitre bah on postule comme
on peut chez carglass chacun
alors la faire brosser il ya une rixe
devant une boîte de nuit et résultat il
a eu une interruption temporaire de
travail de huit jours on travaille
toujours ils filent
veux pas critiquer taxi pape a insulté
le cinéma fatah xi c'est quand même le
seul film au monde qui essaient de faire
croire qu'on peut doubler une porsche
avec une peugeot quoi
affirme éric l'enquète avance alors
apparemment il aurait sauté dans le dos
du skinhead prendre un mec de dos est
décédé à part quand une capote pet
attention je vois que ça crée un malaise
c'est c'est une mort un peu à la con
assurait que le jeune il avait de
l'avenir je veux dire j'ose pas avant de
devenir un mec sérieux il a été trop de
ski ce donc si on avait laissé la paix à
clément peut-être qu'en 2017 et soutenez
nkm ce n'est pas dans la foulée les jnr
ont été dissoutes bah oui c'est serge
ayoub a convoqué ses quatre potes et
leur a dit bon il faut qu'on arrête de
ce soir
on est trop visible un autre mouvement
ça commence c'est très émouvant surtout
lors du vote à main levée
bon coin une famille rom a vendu son
gamin 15000 euros voyez là ça va il a
été rendu il a été rendu belle opération
avec les portefeuilles ramener la
famille affirme plus value de 5000 euros
mariage gay on va finir un peu de
douceur un maire refuse de marier des
gays je vois pas pourquoi on le critique
c'est quand même vachement gentil de sa
part de ne pas vouloir gâcher la fête
tu avais dit le maire il va leur dire
quoi bon bain robert est ce que voulais
vraiment prendre pour épouse sylviane
tille souviens c'est ça moi je peux vous
appeler sylvie parce que sinon regardez
on va pas
[Applaudissements]
maintenant vous trouvez-vous serena pas
vous en bout
je m de dosnon de billets parce que je
suis là j'ai peur
enfin je trouve que c'est vraiment un
acte citoyen de pas célébrer le mariage
quand on n'en a pas les moyens mais je
pense que c'est vachement engagé que je
déjà présentes sauf hier bonne nouvelle
il y en at il une wii hollande rend
hommage à aimé césaire qui salue une
figure intimement liée à l'esprit de la
république bon oui oui en même temps moi
j'écoutais la compagnie créole ce
week-end j'en ai pas fait tout un plat
alors pas mal d'années et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu